um so I've got 200 slides hung a movie
be moving very fast today well not yeah
oh but actually will it will feel that
way oh so yes so well thank you so much
it's an honor to be here are presenting
to all of you today so I'm going to be
talking about a range of projects that
I've been doing it really focuses on you
know how do we take all this data that
we have today and try to use it to
reimagine how we understand ourselves
and the world around us um and this is
really my vision my dream is you know
can we really create over a room of a
fusion center if you will that that
pipes into it every piece of open
information from across the globe it
allows us to see not only what's
happening around the world but what does
underpinnings are what connects it to
the rest of the world how people are
feeling about that in real time um that
this is my vision and how do we start
taking steps towards that well what's
interesting is if you think about you
know for you know think about our this
incredible world that we live in you
know about 50,000 years ago the first
modern humans start walking around I'm
thirty-eight thousand years ago the
first cave painting so the first
surviving others a cave paintings appear
almost from the beginning human start
trying to leave a permanent record of
what of you know what they did what
their feelings are how they understood
the world you know eight thousand years
ago writing begins appearing um and this
is fascinating because the moment that
that society starts being recorded it
allows us to compute on to do so many
different things with it and especially
of course today where people are sort of
you know our virtual and our physical
heartbeats are beginning to beat as one
where people are live digitizing the
world around them and you think about
the spread of electricity you know and
of course this is actually the old image
NASA of course now has has their newer
imagery but you think about you look at
this image and where we have electricity
across the world and then we look at
this image and it may be a little bit
hard to see all actually probably very
hard to see but basically what you're
seeing here red and white are areas
where one or more tweets have been sent
over a period of two thousand eleven or
2012 Oh blue are areas where there's
power but there's been no tweets
recorded from that location oh and
you'll notice that effectively the only
role areas that we see that are
basically in areas that are actually
either banning Twitter or a few other
areas um it turns out that actually
power and Twitter
related about point eight nine spatially
correlated um and so and actually more
power comes more Twitter so effectively
throughout the world where there's power
there's Twitter this is really
fascinating because this really means
that we can observe who can understand
we can measure society and all that
flows through the computation flows
through this this big network of
machines which means that we can observe
that we can try to understand the world
um now of course we shouldn't lose track
of the past and I love this image this
is from the centennial of the nation
from one of the railroad companies I'm
talking about how you know the founding
a nation it was you know Mel was slow
getting information was really really
slow you think about in those days that
you know you could basically put mail
for the train to pick up on its way
who's going that was consistently all
right of me imagine this a letter could
make it halfway across the world well
you know this is also kind of
interesting if we really think about
history and we start reflecting back
think about all these books you know
groups like the Internet Archive I've
been digitizing I mean 600 million pages
they have digitized but you think about
this historically you know libraries
have been digitizing books to focus on
the text to make them full-text
searchable but books aren't just words
their imagery imagine if you could take
for example the OCR so basically the
software that converts those books to be
searchable text and take all the images
that it's recognized and pull all those
out it turns out what you're seeing here
actually is a collage one image from a
book each year so each one it starts
1550 no one 1502 1503 500 years of the
images of the world book books in a
single image here um and this is really
and it turns out actually the technology
behind this is very simple it's a 200
line basically a perl script that did
this what made this so challenging
wasn't the computational aspect of
things it was the data movement each of
these books the original skin imagery
the full resolution imagery behind each
of these books about 500 megabytes to a
gigabyte which doesn't sound much but
you think about that you've got to
stream that across the network you've
got to save that to disk unpack that
repack that read that by time you're
done depending on how you optimize
things you've got several you know
you've got an incredible amount of dis
movement that's happening um and so this
is an interesting project in that the
amount of data a lot of big data today a
lot of the projects they're not just oh
it's all computer it's all you know cpu
intensive so much of it really is is
movement of data
and once we have something like this
once we do this and we create this big
gallery we can start looking at the
history of the world oh and these are
just some great images the upper left is
an image from 1502 you know the cat I
mean 100 years ago I know how many of
you saw the daily mail pieces past
weekend on this project I mean 100 years
ago people were dressing up their cats
you know and I mean cat the cat meme was
alive and well you know we can see the
telephone of all you know from something
of business people you know to to
families you know we can see imagery
historical illustrations historical
photographs of society you know this
this particular the image on the upper
left is really fascinating if you look
closely you'll notice this is an
illustration from about 1640 of
Archimedes setting a boat on fire with a
mirror and of course Mythbusters you
know prove that that wasn't the case
that couldn't have happened but you see
you know the scientific imagery you see
maps you see birds and things dating
backwards through time whatever this
this crazy contraption is here which
allegedly actually was part of a wedding
in the mid-1600s apparently was the
wedding chariot according to the
descriptions um and so this is really
fascinating this ability to really look
back at history you know this is the
cloud 1967 this was the telephone
companies viewed themselves as as the
cloud he knows the data center there in
the center and all the aspects of our
world wrapped around that and you think
about this or my favorite is this this
is an image on the left is from about
1640 and the image on the right is from
about 1680 oh you notice they're so
similar to each other and this actually
was found purely by chance but the
ability now we have 500 years of imagery
in one place we can actually trace out
you know so much of data science today's
focus on text and natural language
processing you think about an image
collection like this that covers almost
every topic imaginable and what you can
do with something like that uh you know
the possibilities are endless well now
of course you know let's fast-forward to
the present what about the social media
world I mean I love this this is the
election of the new pope in 2005 one
little camera phone and of course 2013
you know that the things of flood and
every one of these people it's
broadcasting those views alive to the
world and this is this is very
fascinating if you think about you know
the view that we have of society today
what if we took each of those tweets and
color-coded every one of those tweets by
the language that it was tweeted
we could start making maps that actually
we can zoom in and actually see
Geographic borders we actually see road
networks could actually drill in the
London for example and say people that
normally tweet from Greece when they're
in London what are the parts of London
that they tend to stay around people
from Paris one there there what are the
areas of London that they visit you can
really start observing understanding how
societies are functioning a moment by
moment we can start looking at who's
talking to whom across the world how
communication networks play out in the
social sphere um this is this is one of
my favorites so this is something called
the global Twitter heartbeat that we did
back in 2012 so we want to do there was
actually map the emotion of Twitter in
real time and so we actually I did the
presidential election we did hurricane
saying this is actually a capture of
Hurricane sandy as it was moving up the
coast blue and green or positive red and
orange or negative and what was so fast
thing about this is this is this is
you'll notice an area around New York
which was hit very hard was very
positive you say well how could that
possibly be was what psychologists
called the silver lining affect people
were saying you know we've lost
everything but that everyone's okay even
the dog is okay everyone survived the
house can be replaced and this is
fastened to actually literally see this
play out it and my favorite was and
there's actually a couple movies on
YouTube we made my favorites your
literacy literally see people tweet um
you know the glad the all the windows
are shattered the roof is starting to
crack and come down I should probably
get out of my house and I love that
people's first you know first uh you
know uh thing they do today is a tweet
about it not to not to get out of there
I think that says something about about
society today and you think about this
you know how else could we use something
like this um so NBC approached me on
this past fall and said we want to
rethink the future of interactive
television and if you think about what
is television you know will the model of
television give viewers what they want
well what if we could actually see what
you know what if we could actually
observe what the fans of a show want in
real time and actually adjust the show
in real time to address that so we
actually debuted this would sci-fi with
their new show collapse at Worlds it was
a very interesting show I mean the first
episode they actually had them go up on
a platform with actually literally
straight out Star Wars a Taser on a
stick and literally or on this 20-foot
high platform trying to tase the other
person to fall off the platform is a
very very interesting show but my aspect
of it was was this part on the right
which will
is the will be calling the Twitter
popularity index so what we want to do
is measure the emotion around each of
the characters on Twitter and actually
rank that and of course sentiment mining
is one of the hottest areas today but
what's interesting is that about ninety
seven percent of the literature on
sentiment mining today comes from
computer science measuring the motion is
not a computer science problem no yes
you need tools to be able to do that but
it's kind of odd to me that all of the
work that's being done on improving how
we measure a motion on line is you know
the psychologist the communications
folks very few of those are involved in
the field right now almost be
interesting because part of this project
we did a big piece of wired on this
because it actually started drilling
down you find out for example um that
you know it used to be people would say
I love this show hashtag oppositeworlds
today they'll say hashtag I love Joe Jr
so much opposite worlds so the entire
treat will be one single hashtag you're
fine at least in the entertainment world
which is very different than many other
disciplines so that meant all of a
sudden that we had to really reshape how
we think about measuring this so this
really sort of involved how do we step
back and treat this not as a not as a
technology problem but actually as an
underlying disciplinary problem and this
is this has been a big focus I think
that as big data is maturing we really
need sort of a bringing together of the
of the computer science folks and you
know and and the and the Disciplinary
folks because something for example
building a dictionary of say colloquial
expressions you know jump the shark you
know these are things that very few
computer scientists are focusing on
because it's difficult to collect
colloquial expressions improperly
understand the boundaries of that
expression and the polarity of that it's
difficult to do that reliably within the
space you get a lot of a lot of oddities
let's put it that way um and and so so
yeah so there's there's a lot of
interesting it's a pretty interesting
world that we live in today the ability
to bring these together and if you think
about for example of course television
you know the Internet Archive has you
know one of the largest you know
collections of television out there so
this project really start with you think
about we have this enormous archive of
you know more than half a million hours
of or nearly half a million hours of
closed captioning all these shows what's
the geography of American television
look like today what do they actually
you know when someone turns on the TV at
night to watch the news what are they
actually seeing are they saying just
America are they seeing the Middle East
they see Europe
well this is what they're saying um so
what we did is actually take all that
closed captioning stream and actually
identify every Geographic reference and
all that there's actually an animated
map you guys should move the time slider
forward pick a particular day zoom in
click and actually hop right to the
actual snippets of the shows that
mention that particular location you can
drill down and switch between CNN and
Fox News and MSNBC and see well CNN's
emphasizing this week they're focusing
on this but Fox News is ignoring that
and they're focusing on this issue so
its ability to really peel back the
layers and say you know we have these
incredible archives that are there how
do we start you know applying new types
of new approaches on whether technology
or meth illogical to those to understand
them a new light on this project in the
upper left so this was listed
collaboration with the the the historian
of the US State Department and Columbia
University we were interested in all the
Declassified Kissinger era State
Department cable so these are
essentially their email system of the
70s where they're sending you know basic
communications between all the embassies
how do you visualize what's basically
you think about you know about one and a
half million essentially emails you know
how do you visualize something like that
if you just make a network diagram of
that on a map it's a spaghetti it just
lines everywhere um so there's actually
a collaboration actually with the Google
viz team we actually got to use their
what they call the armed globe and what
you do is you pick a country and we
actually displayed that the network
actually centered on that country so
it's sort of a geographically centered
network visualization this is actually
blue is incoming cables redder outgoing
cables you can actually literally watch
you guys should move a time slaughter
and say Brazil over time how did the
traffic from the US missions in Brazil
how did those flow throughout the rest
of the world and you actually see for
example a country will all of a sudden
it'll start accepting information from
all of the US missions around it and
then it alone will stream that 2d to
Washington and then you'll see all of a
sudden all the embassies will start
relating to Washington cici's fascinate
characteristics are their huge
diplomatic scholars that we've never
been able to do before you know the data
has been there actually the davis been
digitized for a while now what we lacked
was a visualization modality that allows
us to really interact and understand
that on the google constitute project so
this was the case where all these
constitutions have existed around the
world so this is I'm actually a Tom
Ginsberg and Zack Elkins are the leads
on this on what but the problem here
that we had was
have all these these paper constitutions
I mean the rate basically the records of
the world back to 1789 oh and so how do
we how do we sort of systematize
collecting those across the world
digitizing those I'm encoding those and
they actually pull out about 1200
questions you know can the president
fire Congress and all these specific
questions encoded in that how do you
deal with this when this is multiplied
across every language of the world over
200 years who is the but you know who
does the most accurate coding of a
constitution a spanish-language
Constitution from 200 years ago how do
we deal how do we integrate machine
translation all these other aspects into
it this image and lower right is from a
prototype where we're taking actually
the entirety of the internet archives
book collection the entirety of the
hypha trust collection and a couple
other peripheral collections including
one of the largest collections of
Diaries on letters from the Civil War
and we're actually visualizing the
American Civil War a year by year
through the eyes of all the material
from that time pair and actually
understand the flow of ideas the things
like states rights where did those start
emerging how did those start mixing with
other ideas how do those themes begin
blending and intersecting very
fascinating abilities to really
visualize the flow of information this
is a project we did with silicon
graphics and wikipedia where you think
about what competed today wikipedia is
still you know you searched my text box
a decade after its creation you still
were typing in a keyword search to
interact with it but as encyclopedia you
think about it you know it's so rich
with geographic information so we did
here was actually extract out every
geographic reference from the text about
any million locations about 40 million
dates and actually build a huge network
diagram over all that and so you know if
it says in Paris an 18 set of 37 that
actually becomes a dot in a map if it
says in London later that year that kiss
canister there's actually a visual
network animation we did that shows
world history but this is a google earth
visualization where you can actually
take a country like Libya to move the
time slider down to particular time
period and we'll show you every location
in Libya discussed with respect to that
time period across all of the
english-language wikipedia so then you
can drill in click on that hop right to
that location within that article and it
turns out actually the majority of the
information on libya doesn't come from
libyan page it comes from everything out
you know there'll be something about a
plant species was discovered in an 18-3
seven British expedition to some City
you'd never think to go look at this
particular plant species for you know
information about the history of Libya
there's ability to really look at
information in it through a new light
through knew him from through new lenses
and of course that brings me back to
this this notion of how do we observe
the entire world what if you could build
essentially a platform that observed all
society at wants um and so that that's
basically what what I focus on and so
this particular project so the GTO gdelt
project that work so the goal of this
project is you know what if we could
collect all of the large fraction of all
the news media worldwide every day in
about a hundred different languages
print broadcast web across the planet
scoop all that up and prostitute
partnerships with with media
organizations throughout the world and
process all that computationally and
basically build this massive catalogue
of human society oh and of course in
parallel to this the percentage of all
media worldwide that's available from
the web is skyrocketing over time by
2010 almost half of all news Mia
worldwide was web published and that's
critical because the get for example at
a to wat broadcaster in southern
Zimbabwe is very difficult to get at
that type of radio station you you
actually have to partner with groups
that are throughout the world to get
that the more that's web accessible the
easier it is to monitor this across the
world and so what it allows us to do is
essentially transform the war transform
the news of the world are into maps and
so what you end up with is something
like this a sentence that says you know
Iraq criticized Turkey on Monday for
bombing Kurdish militants in northern
Iraq so you have a typical news article
sentient you know and this is just one
sentence of a news article and the
computer basically processes that and
says there's two things going on here
one is that a rat criticized Turkey and
the second one is that turkey bomb
Kurdish militants in Iraq so this
textual news article becomes basically a
series of database entries which means
then that we can take all this pile of
news media that's breaking as as Egypt
was collapsing again last year we can
scoop up all they they will lose me
beyond that and make a real-time map
that was updating minute by minute of
what was happening across Egypt at that
moment that was reported in the news
media anywhere in the world we can also
then extract out every person
organization location theme out of that
and build a huge knowledge graph over
all that that allows us to place in the
context who's involved with these
located with these things for example or
protests in Egypt on that the Muslim
Brotherhood is part of
is much more important than an ordinary
protest for example um and of course you
know news media alone isn't isn't quite
enough this is a huge collaborations
going to be announced about a week or so
um so basically what we did here are so
this was of the this is actually the
entirety of JSTOR's holdings the
entirety of unclassified dtic which is
basically all military and intelligence
publication output the US government and
then scanning of the internet archives
PDF archive looking for anything that
was reports academic literature
dissertations etc and actually codify
this about 21 billion words of academic
literature about Africa the Middle East
oh and the interesting that the question
here the idea here was to say could you
make essentially a fine an expert
service we could zoom in and say you
know I'm interested in you know water
water scarcity in with the NORs in this
area of South Sudan for the top five
experts today the top five academic
experts in the world on this you can
actually drill in on a map actually
circle that area and actually return and
actually go through the citation grass
of all these papers on actually process
that and say here the top experts that
are that specialize in this you can
drill and here's actually a very
interesting set of maps oh here's the
geographic footprint of not where
they're published but basically what's
the geographic focus of papers of US
government literature you'll notice very
very operational focusing just on where
the US has interests today academic
literature on the other hand is much
much closer to what the news media focus
is on so a this tells us the US
government is is really the literature
that the State Department that that you
know the military and all these other
groups what they're focusing on that the
issues that they're studying are
basically yesterday's issues not what it
what not word are emerging tomorrow
what's also interesting is that the
academic literature is so close to the
news media and there were a lot of
questions of you know high conflict
zones in Congo for example would you
really have a lot of literature on these
conflict zones well it turns out that's
because you know people have studied
those for long periods of time we can
also do things you'll make interactive
maps you can actually watch things like
the Ukraine crisis unfold Nigeria unfold
we can make conflict map so you guys
should make this actually a daily PDF
report that's summarizing what's going
on around the world today what's its
contact
ah make actually a trends report so you
can actually take for example a leader
like like Maduro actually make basing
essentially a word cloud of what are all
the other world leaders and people that
are contextualized long that what are
the connections among world leaders this
actually is a daily report that actually
measures every world leader and how
global news tone about that leader is
shifting over time it turns out this
actually has some very fascinating
abilities to actually give you some
really interesting estimates as to what
that leaders is going to be doing soon
here's an example of taking everything
set around the world about the make
about the Mexican drug cartels and
actually basically saying anything
worldwide and the news me about the
Mexican drug cartels make a heat map of
that turns out this actually matches de
A's map I'm very very closely at the
time period this was made we can take
all the world's ethic groups that are in
the news made actually look in five
years segments over the last quarter
century how the world's ethnic group so
this is basically Co mentions and
interactions record in the news media of
the world's ethnic groups and how they
form these these fascinating complex
patterns over time now whether this is a
reality of the world's ethnic groups are
interacting you know more in a different
fashion today or whether the news or
whether the news media is changing its
portrayal of those you know we're taking
the first steps towards being able to
view that being able to take something
like the Affordable Health Care Act and
actually measuring the emotion of
American new American news media in
real-time and watching you know how
things how the media reacts to that the
ability for example to take something
say the Nigerian oil and gas industry oh
and actually build a spreadsheet in real
time they actually tells you who are the
top 20 most influential people in the
Nigerian oil and gas industry I'm be
able to separate that out by government
officials by domestic foreign and so on
it turns out this actually matches
actually a ground truth quite quite
closely we can do things for example we
can take we can go bye-bye month over
the last quarter century and say what is
the total intensity of protest activity
worldwide and we see that post the Arab
Spring there's been enormous leap right
there right there at the end you know
there's been an enormous increase
actually in global protest activity
post-arab spring
that's only for that we only see that
because for last 20 years it's been
relatively quiet we're basically back
where we were in the 80s which of course
you know had the fall of the Soviet
Union and all these other things and we
can put in the context things like
Ukraine and other events we can make a
network diagram and basically extract
out so this is done for foreign policy
last December pulled out every person i
mention in the world's news media over
to over a large fraction of 2013 oh and
basically made a huge network diagram
connecting all those and then what
you're seeing here it's hard to see on
the screen you're actually seeing these
fascinating communities and how the
different how the different groups of
the world I'm interacting are portrayed
to the world's news media this is a new
collaboration with the u.s. Institute of
Peace there's actually a live map
updated right now each day very shortly
every 15 minutes we're actually we're
mapping all the world's protests and
pink and violence in red and this is
actually filtered that's why you don't
see as much in Latin America this is
filtered for larger scale things are
happening a particular day see ability
to actually observe and you guys you
then drill in click it actually see
what's going on at this particular
region so the way you're sort of drawing
your eye is saying you know what's this
thing that we're missing over here this
is actually an animated map it actually
shows you the last hundred eighty days
so as you actually look at this you
literally see the moment that Isis
begins to get traction from the earliest
stages you actually see that you
actually see their motion across the
country if you drill into Nigeria you
can actually see Boko Haram you can
actually see it start taking Russia
actually see as it gains territory falls
back you can actually see as it's
bursting as its gaining is it sort of
hopping and gaining new territory and
then joining that together you start
seeing all these spatial patterns but
perhaps most fascinating is is this map
um so this was basically the the
question behind this is you've got a
quarter of a billion records of riots
protest cruise etc every country a city
level on 1979 the present what if you
could say give me the last two months of
Ukraine make a timeline of the of the
intensity of unrest in that country by
by day and then look in a rolling window
over the entire last quarter century it
basically take a two month rolling
window over every country over you know
over the last 35 years and basically say
the last two months of Ukraine what are
all the points in what are all the
periods in history that are most similar
to right now and basically to mass
cross-correlation to an F million
correlations and take the ones that are
most similar average those together and
it turns out basically what you're
seeing here
is red is actually what happened in
green was actually the forecast you get
from this and basically there's a it's a
little bit hard to see up here oh but it
turns out this actually gives you some
incredibly accurate forecasts actually
for Egypt for Ukraine for a lot of the
recent crises that have been going on
and basically what's interesting about
this is this was actually using so
Google has something called bigquery
which is a big database engine um this
is a single line of SQL quote two and a
half minutes to do two and a half
million correlations and so it's so fast
i'm at this is is we've reached a point
normally to do to do something of this
massive you know say i want to run
basically massive exhaustive cross
correlation of a data set I want to see
all the patterns that are here you know
that would require writing enormous
amount of code and doing all kinds of
really in-depth analyses and that's the
amazing part today is that with with the
cloud infrastructure we have today with
the platforms that we have and and and
the tools are out there the ability to
to be able to sift out to start sifting
out these parents now again I'm overtime
now but again you know what you're
seeing here is a cross between the
reality of society and the news media's
portrayal society but for the first time
we're able to start sifting out those
patterns so whether these are you know
the psychohistorical equations of life
doubtful or more likely a more precise
mathematical on measuring of how media
portrays the world were able for the
first time start taking the taking those
steps towards it and creating that you
know that that person vision of it so
there's my contact information if your
interest thank you so much